on poursuit cette ut week end avec
stéphane veyer qui vient de nous
rejoindre vous êtes directeur adjoint du
pôle formation du centre d'enseignement
aux techniques basées à rambouillet à la
bergerie nationale
il se compose de deux établissements
publics on va le voir tout de suite et
il faut savoir qu'ils ouvrent leurs
portes au public demain samedi 27 avril
est aussi le 25 mai l'occasion de
découvrir votre offre de formation et
aussi ce nouveau brevet que vous
proposerait dès la rentrée de septembre
alors le jargon dit bpr e âge donc ses
brevets professionnels responsables
d'entreprises hippiques
alors c'est fade weyer quels sont les
publics concernés on va commencer par le
cfa donc le centre de formation
d'apprentis
bonjour oui effectivement alors ce
diplôme et un diplôme de niveau iv du
ministère de l'agriculture il
est proposé aux jeunes dans le cadre de
l'apprentissage qui ont entre 16 et 25
ans évidemment c'est un diplôme qui
idéalement vient en plus d'un diplôme de
niveau 5 type c ap ou bep ce diplôme est
poursuit assez bien dans la filière
hippique parlera suit un cap à soigneur
d'équidés par exemple on retrouve
la particularité de ce de la mise en
place de ce nouveau diplôme est liée à
la capacité à l'installation
l'apport intéressant et capitale de ce
diplôme est d'accéder au statut de jeune
agriculteur d'accord donc là pour le cfa
les jeunes concernés sont plutôt des
années qui ont décroché on peut dire
alors ça peut être des jeunes qui ont
décroché en tout cas ce sont des jeunes
qui n'ont sûrement pas eu la capacité de
poursuivre une filière générale
évidemment qu'ils n'ont pas pu non plus
aller vers une filière bac professionnel
en trois ans un jeune typiquement sorte
de troisième
s'il ne va pas vers un bac général il
peut faire le choix d'aller vers un bac
par la filière professionnelle en train
en seconde professionnelle première et
terminale et sert ce qu'ils ne font ni
ce parcours ni l'onu pour une deuxième
peuvent aller vers 1 1 c'est ap et à
l'issue d'un ce et ap normalement on
doit travailler
or certains dans le cas de sauce et ape
retrouve goût à la scolarité et parfois
on retrouve un petit peu une utilité
professionnelle et souhaitent accéder à
un niveau supérieur de diplôme qui leur
donne des des compétences surtout liée à
la partie organisation gestion d'une
entreprise qui n'abordait pas elana
contenu est allégé au niveau des
matières pour la partie cfa pour les
apprentis ça le professionnel et
technique voilà c'est ça le contenu est
allégé par rapport à un bac
professionnel un bac professionnel on va
avoir des modules généraux de matières
générales et les modules de matières
professionnelles dans le cas d'un bpr h
on est sur un diplôme qui est construit
autour des diplômes professionnels et on
va y retrouver par exemple du français
éventuellement demain en plus pour la
communication professionnelle
on va poursuivre au cfppa qui est le
centre de formation professionnelle et
de promotion agricole donc fait pour des
jeunes qui sont déjà un peu diplômés
pour compléter leur formation et vous
disiez que c'était pour accéder au
statut de jeune agriculteur très
rapidement quels sont les avantages
d'avoir ce statut il vient ce statut
actuellement permet d'accéder aux
dotations jeunes agriculteurs par
exemple
l'important c'est surtout lié à une
personne qui souhaite ou reprendre une
exploitation existantes ou bien en
acheter une autre ou en créer une
et dans ce cadre là le milieu du cheval
le secteur hi fi qui est encore du
domaine agricole et
là on va dire les structures régionales
de l'agriculture permettent d'aider ces
personnes à s'installer dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
d'accord et vous proposez aussi une
autre formation que les jeunes pourront
découvrir demain donc lors des portes
ouvertes
il s'agit du captage donc certificat
d'aptitude professionnelle au transport
d'animaux vivants puisque la
réglementation a changé
quel est son but alors son but est
simplement d'apporter aux personnes qui
souhaitent effectuer le transport dans
un cadre lucratif et dans des zones
géographiques des points 165km d'être en
respect de la réglementation le contenu
de la formation va être orientée autour
la physiologie de l'animal va être
orienté aussi sur la réglementation les
documents et voilà c'est ça on est avec
la mise en voix hors norme de l'europe
on est sur les contraintes assez
importantes qui sont nouvelles et qui
sont assez peu appliquée on va dire le
mieux du sol pas assez et du coup voilà
cette formation aujourd'hui elle permet
à tous les personnes qui n'ont pas un
diplôme agricole qui permet d'obtenir
d'équivalence de se former pour
effectuer le transport des animaux
sinon on risque une amende et une amende
voire peut-être l'immobilisation du
véhicule et des animaux trop forte donc
c'est pas ce que c'est pas le filtre à
l'agréable
quand ça arrive donc voilà ce sont au
moins deux formations que vous proposez
au sein de votre pôle formation au sein
de la bergerie nationale de rambouillet
merci stéphane veyer pour ces
indications je rappelle que votre pool
organise donc des portes ouvertes demain
et le 25 mai